what is up guys so now that fall is
officially here Wow weird summer cool
fall is officially here whether we like
it or not and I actually really like the
first month to fall I have a lot of fun
with the first month of fall because of
the weather the way it feels the
crispness there's a whole new different
type of movie season as well going on
right now that you can get into I want
to talk to you guys about the remaining
films that are coming out this year that
I'm looking forward to the most this
fall and winter you guys been wondering
about that you've been asking me
questions on Twitter and Facebook
what are you most looking forward to
movies now the summer is over I thought
hey why not let's talk about him now
I've already seen a few of them for
instance I've already seen gravity which
I really enjoyed my review for that is
currently up right now the next film I'm
very much interested in comes out very
soon it's called captain Phillips the
movies with Tom Hanks is directed by
Paul Greengrass it's a true story about
a boat captain and pirates take over his
boat not the Captain Jack Sparrow type
of pirates with modern-day type of
pirates I think Paul Greengrass is one
of the only directors who can actually
make shakey cam look like an art form
still and not just some crazy gimmick so
that film definitely still has my
interest and of course Tom Hanks is a
humongous draw as well also in the month
of October machete kills and carry two
films I'm a little curious about Carrie
for one is another horror remake so who
knows if that's gonna be any good it has
good actors in it that's for sure
it's just that I don't know really what
it can do that's different from the
original which I thought was very good
directed by Brian De Palma machete kills
looks like it could be a fun sequel
Danny Trejo and Mel Gibson just hamming
it up purposely I'm interested in seeing
that but I'm not like deathly curious
about it I think it could be fun and
hopefully it is we also have a skate
plan formerly known as the tomb with
Arnold Schwarzenegger and Sylvester
Stallone just those two actors in a
movie together I'm automatically
interested even if it's corny and cheesy
as hell yes stolen was in rocky and
Arnold made great films like Terminator
and Predator but to me they fill this
awesome 80's early 90's void of action
that we don't really get that much of
anymore the counselor I don't know much
about except for a fantastic cast and
it's directed by Ridley Scott and I like
the fact that the trailers don't give
them much away I loved Ridley Scott
films he does have some hits and some
misses but when he does well it's great
and hopefully the counselor is pretty
great I'm excited to see what he's got
up his sleeve
November we had this movie called
Ender's Game
it stars Asa Butterfield Hailee
Steinfeld and Harrison Ford as well as
Ben Kingsley the cast interests me
because it has two really great young
actress we haven't really seen that much
from Hailee Steinfeld since True Grit
and of course the great Harrison Ford
and the great Ben Kingsley were in the
film as well I just hope it's as good as
the trailers are trying to make it look
because I'm not really seeing a moment
that's like oh wow that looks awesome it
just looks interesting based off the
cast and the plot but I hope the film
and the story actually delivers as well
now one of my most anticipated movies
for the rest of the year is definitely
Thor the dark world I enjoyed the first
Thor but I really do think there's a lot
of room for improvement there hopefully
this film builds upon the story that's
already been set up that's one of the
cool things about these Marvel movies is
since they're all related now they can
all build on this universe and this
story and it feels deeper than just one
film now whenever Martin Scorsese comes
out with a new film I'm automatically
excited purely based off the fact that
he's an incredible director and one of
my favorite directors the wolf of Wall
Street has Leonardo DiCaprio and a sort
of business financial money scams
scandalous type film and that's
something that Martin Scorsese I just
think he's gonna own it I sort of get
this catch me if you can vibe from the
trailer not just because it has Leo
DiCaprio in it but because of the whole
money and scam related things about it
I'm really interested in seeing what
Martin Scorsese is gonna bring to the
screen because he makes every scene pop
every camera pan and turn always has
something cool behind it and I'm hoping
that the wolf of Wall Street delivers as
a film as well another sequel that I'm
hoping improves upon the first one is
the new Hunger Games film Catching Fire
I enjoyed the first film but like Thor I
thought there was a lot of room for
improvement and I think that they can do
that they've changed the director and I
really think the trailer was interesting
it looked a lot more steady a lot less
shaky-cam which is something that as I
said earlier I think a few directors can
really pull off successfully I'm not
huge into the books but I'm interested
in the story I'm curious to see where it
goes now December we have a lot of
really interesting films because that's
where they try to cram all the big Oscar
stuff and then Christmas always has a
whole bunch of great films one of the
first films in December I'm very curious
about is out of the furnace with
Christian Bale Woody Harrelson Casey
Affleck that film looks fantastic I'm
truly excited to see that movie for the
performances for the interesting story
because I read up a little bit on the
plot and I
want to know anything else but it
definitely interests me anything
Christian Bale does nowadays I'm
instantly 100% wanting to be there
because that guy is an actor who gives
his all to his performances unlike most
actors working today I mean physically
he changes his body all the time he
really gets into character a lot I'm
really excited to see what he does with
that movie also Casey Affleck is another
actor that really tries to gravitate
towards really good projects and I'm
hoping that out of the furnace is
definitely one of those because I'm very
interested in seeing that one another
film that I think could improve upon the
first one is Hobbit - I liked the first
one I didn't hate it or anything but I
do think it could have been a little bit
better but I think the second film can
really build upon the first one just
like I've been talking about with Thor
and Hunger Games - I really think this
film can build upon what's already there
and make a better film there's a lot
more to the Hobbit story now they're
getting into the best part of the Hobbit
story I think hopefully they'll be able
to condense it to the point where you
don't feel like it's just really
stretched out trilogy because it's
really just one book hopefully this one
can be more meaty and feel like there's
more depth going on there Peter Jackson
is always fantastic with visuals and I'm
really interested to see what he does
there and my most anticipated comedy for
the rest of the year is definitely
anchorman - anchorman is a film that I
saw in theaters on a first came out and
for some reason I just didn't get it and
then I saw it again and suddenly I got
it I don't know what it was anchorman is
one of the funniest films I've seen it's
just so absurdly silly and it has so
many great lines in there that I have
quoted many times throughout the course
of my life and I'm hoping that anchorman
2 is similar in that way and that it
doesn't feel like a cash grab or like
they're just making a sequel trying to
emulate the first film or the success of
the first one I'm hoping it can feel
like its own thing as well while still
being hilarious
monuments men is also coming out and
that's the new George Clooney movie I
don't know much about this film I just
know that George Clooney directs films
very well and he brings great casts in
and I've heard really good things about
the way the filming in the production
went a lot of the cast members are
really excited about the movie so I'm
hoping that one's pretty good
now here's a film that we haven't really
seen a trailer for that I don't
understand why actually because it's
coming out pretty soon we really haven't
seen anything about this movie except a
couple production photos but Jack Ryan
the new reboot of the character Jack
Ryan is coming out with Chris Pine and
Kevin Costner haven't seen a thing about
this movie it's coming out pretty soon
so I'm a little worried
that actually but I mean major said just
because of the character alone because I
am a fan of the original films not so
much the sum of all fears but I liked
Hunt for Red October Patriot Games and
clear and present danger very much
hopefully this one follows in those
footsteps where it's an intense
political thriller that feels like it
has real world connections as well those
were some of the best elements of the
first ones and lastly the secret life of
walter mitty ben stiller Zanu film looks
really cool if you haven't seen his
trailer for this movie it looks pretty
awesome I don't know how he's gonna tell
this story because it's about a guy who
likes to live in his dreams and his
imagination and then you get to see what
he's imagining that could make for some
really great imagery but I hope that
there's also a cool story to go along
with that cool imagery so those are some
of my most anticipated films for the
rest of the year what are some of your
guys most anticipated films for the rest
of this year I'm curious if you agree
with me what your thoughts are on some
of the films I said or if there's
anything I may have missed let me know
below I tried to get everything in there
as best I could I tried guys thanks very
much for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes